Oh Oh [ __ ] I don't know buttons but you
learn to him oh boy
come on get out come on go go okay that
ship oh yeah [ __ ] how to play
this I don't like it but I can either
for Jack oh I'm not in the back row
what's happening now I can stop it but
he can't make it
shut up so [ __ ] frustrating if only
my hey that's the sweetie I got it I got
it
what am i back in there hey I am are
your car up things I hate this game so
much
[ __ ] go
Oh No hey we changed colors the well
okay I'll go ball cam I didn't know that
yeah it's Brian Gold your best friend
okay oh [ __ ] the ball I got this I got
it
the bone is [ __ ] upside down
how'd I get here I can't just do
something good in cheeks girl oh [ __ ]
you [ __ ] hit me
no no give me groans different cameras
this is unfair Oh at that on goal yeah
he was it really then I just came out of
nowhere and bam
you did a jack shut up you don't know my
life
[ __ ] yes oh yeah [ __ ] all right
this is the longest one count ever oh my
gosh
Oh faster get it ran a while one one
we're gonna do the same teams now just
because of that
yeah
no you're really really good no I've
been trying to suck really hard yeah I
pushed you I'm sorry and within one
second
the orange team have scores a proper
goal alright you only score those satyr
like me like so god damn [ __ ] bowling
without a [ __ ] are you [ __ ] doing
oh why are you jumping this is you you
try to be a gold yeah oh my god you guys
have so much taste laughing it's okay
oh my god it's so [ __ ] close they're
stover Brad yeah serious with this [ __ ]
oh go ahead I got the ball Oh miss if I
got the ball for Sweden Sweden Sweden up
behind doing that you [ __ ] laughing
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
ha ha oh don't push it
don't touch it wait [ __ ] go all right
look at this
yeah look I don't rip it yeah like that
get it in let that ball go inside look
put up five [ __ ] in yeah what the [ __ ]
you saying it to [ __ ] point